[Music]
they really struggled all these mixed
feelings of depression and gen genuine
loneliness I didn't see a point of being
around if I was going to be alone I
realized I hadn't actually properly read
the Quran so I tried to do that
there were many parts that I didn't
think were very fair specially on women
I decided until I get the answers that I
wanted I couldn't pray to a god that I
didn't really think was there or if he
was wasn't really listening to me so I
decided to take off the headscarf very
quickly the situation deteriorated
I was actually stalked and given a death
threat by family member it's hard enough
going through the thoughts and finally
gaining courage to be able to say
something so big as you know I don't
believe in Islam anymore but to have it
immediately thrown back at you dismissed
I was terrified people are under the
impression that you know Oh leave
religion that's it you go out your party
all the time
you drink loads now that you can and
there are so many ideas that that I grew
up with that came from culture and
religion that my my parents taught me
that I've still stayed with me how much
is a single hex cup two pounds each my
taking off my hats got really shocked
people I think that was the biggest step
for me because that was something that
I've been wearing for eight years I
can't look back at pictures without
seeing me in a headscarf
but your hair has to be completely tied
back
minute all the way around or whatever
like that kind of thing
[Music]
we started to an events at university
was called coming out events we just had
loads of xmas from playing their stories
and wanted people to know that they
weren't alone cuz I grew up and called
conservative religious school I maybe it
wouldn't have taken me until I was 19 to
to to sort of come to a point where I
don't really believe in it and and to
move away the Islam that I grew up in
that had been you know shoved down my
throat for years was actually being
shoved down my throat to actually
control me to control what I did and why
I warned who I spoke to and how I ate
and how I thought the taboo of apostasy
is so deep it's a bit like it's a bit
like being gay
most gay people grow up in a society
where from a very young age they told
that the norm is a mana Norman and
everybody else is bizarre ex-muslim grew
up in the same sort of environments
where they're told from a very young age
that everyone should be a Muslim anyway
but if you're pulling to Islam you are
essentially born into privilege so why
would you leave
[Music]
we don't have the auntie who became an
ex-muslim and it's over we don't have a
sister who left Islam and everyone sort
reet's her like a normal part of this
family
what we have is family members that go
missing the sister that no one speaks to
anymore
the cousin no bean has no idea which
they live or how many more those are the
X Muslims
you
you
[Music]